what did you think of the win for
sterling uh I thought it was wonderful
you know I'm very happy for him
Oh Jay Simpson prosecutor Chris Darden
reacts to sterling K Browns big Emmy win
for playing him on American crime story
Darden tells et he still hasn't watched
the hit show but that he was rooting for
Brown I knew that he was playing an
interesting complicated conflicted
character and and how could he lose he
told us that he has tried to reach out
to you has not heard from you I called
him before and he respectfully declined
I don't think it would be right to call
him again
what if he called you today after this
Emmy win
sterling hey brown the big shot
Hollywood actor Emmy Award winning actor
now that guy oh I have to take his call
what means you not answer at the time
mystery o'clock in the morning you know
and I was concerned about my parents
that night and I thought to you know
when the phone rang that there was a
problem but it was just sterling K Brown
maybe it's part of the reason why I have
never really connected you know what
sterling for me and there's a hugely
negative life experience and for me to
have to revisit it really just drags me
to a very dark and angry place that I
don't want to go you know I don't want
to go back there and I'm gonna go back
to 1995 and I don't want to feel the way
I felt in 1995 so I think for for
sterling you know he was in a position
to look at all of that footage and
researched me and researched the case
and decide for himself who that who the
character really is I don't know whether
he got it right but you got it right
enough apparently Darden is now re
releasing his book in contempt which
details his experience during the
Simpson trial
you